[Music]
my goal in changing education is to
allow kids to have some control over
what they're learning
[Music]
boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Don sake on
very very excited and grateful to be
talking about how to raise successful
people we have joining us the godmother
of Silicon Valley Esther Wojcicki hello
hello I am so excited to be here well
I'm honored thank you so much likewise
extremely grateful your work over the
years has been so profoundly impactful
on our entire world so we're gonna have
a blast unpacking this super pumped for
those that don't know Esther's
background
s-sir is the author of how to race
successful people that's coming out in
May check that out in the links below
also the author of moonshots in
education that link is below as well
she's known as the godmother of Silicon
Valley also is the most influential
educator in contemporary times she has a
pedagogy called trick which stands for
trust respect independence collaboration
and kindness and she's for 36 years been
in passing along scholastic journalism
into our world in programs in high
schools and beyond her Palo Alto media
arts center has 700 students at it right
now and she's raised three of the most
successful women in the United States
she consults at the Department of
Education she's the vice chair at
Creative Commons chief Learning Officer
a plan of three what do you not do is
the better question you have such an
epic epic background yes sir well I'm
not the world's greatest cook yes and
and all of these links are below for
everyone to explore Esther let's start
with this listen the the wash way the
wash way yeah watch way I love it I love
it and the kids embody this too it's so
beautiful
start with this big history perspective
we find ourselves as stewards of Earth
what is your current take on the state
of humanity
well I would say the current state of
humanity it needs a lot of help we have
had a lot of problems and we and they
get seem to be getting worse not better
and so I'm an optimist I really believe
in people I think that the basic human
being is a good person and wants to do
the right thing somehow we get diverted
and somehow we get our opinions change
for no logical reason and so we end up
sort of being angry and nasty to each
other when in fact there's no reason why
this should be happening the world is
actually in a much better place than
it's ever been there are fewer people in
poverty than ever before but we are
still fighting with each others like
crazy and we don't respect each other
it's a major problem and so I have taken
on this Herculean effort but which is a
little crazy
but I'd like to make people aware of
that that actually you will be happier
lead a much more satisfying life you
will be passionate about the things
you're doing when you're doing things to
make the world a better place and it
starts early very early as a matter of
fact should I tell you how early yes
what's this this synthesis is fantastic
and yeah it does start very early it's
kind of like our next big thing is that
you ages zero to five are so crucial and
we like to you know we're talking about
certain we'd like to think of things as
seeds children are seeds they need the
right nutrients that's absolutely true
so you know that little baby you just
gave birth to or you know our nurturing
in your house it's much smarter than you
think much smarter and it's picking up
all these clues I don't care if it can't
walk yet and whether it can't you know
feed itself yet I'm telling you it's
learning
and so what you're doing it's observing
it's kind of interesting to see how
different children are from different
cultures you know so you go to them to
like Japan for example and you compare
the children in Japan with maybe the
children in Italy or maybe friends they
all they can't their pre verbal but they
all have picked up the culture already
they're like their parents and their
parents haven't lectured them they're
not taking a test they are that's who
they are
I mean every one of them comes into the
world it's like a flower you have to
take care of it and nurture it or like a
plant or a tree yes they're all special
so you have to take really good care of
them and you have to realize that they
are learning early on yes and not only
that they do what they see you doing
this yes yes this this this is this is
one of the quotes in your book Khalil
Gibran quote your children are not your
children they are the sons and daughters
of life's longing for itself they come
through you but not from you and though
they are with you yet they belong not to
you and you have another phrase in your
book your child is not your clone and
we're gonna unpack that as well this was
one that's so deeply resonated with me
you know let's just dive a little bit
deeper into this age zero to five this
you're right it's just they're just
processing the stimuli of their
environment from the moment they're born
into it that's right so what are they
absorbing are they absorbing stress is
there food insecurity because that's
gonna cause stress is there yelling
happening around them that's gonna cost
stress is do they have the creative toys
and and an experiences fresh air all the
water the loving and compassion of a
mother right and father are they gonna
have that and so all these things mold
what the child becomes an
these are such formative years but
they're really formative years and a lot
I know a lot of people don't think of
their children like that they're just
like oh the baby's over there and I'm
not kidding
do you see the baby well it's not doing
much of anything right now no but
honestly that baby is doing more than
you think it's doing and so one of the
areas that I think parents get trapped
in you know right away the baby comes
home from the hospital with the mom and
dad and then that's like well should we
put them in a separate room you know you
know maybe he's gonna be lonely in there
no no let's put them in well she'll
sleep right here in the same bed right
so it's a movement called Co sleeping Co
sleeping yep interesting this is so
interesting when you wrote this in your
book about how you just you you birth a
child into the world and then you're
holding it in the hospital and then what
is it three days yeah you get in the
hospital and then all of a sudden it's
like good luck and have fun it's like
good luck good effort I had to request
an extra day in the hospital because I
didn't know how to change diapers give
the child a bath and so forth all these
things and but I'm telling you that they
learn early on what what your they can
sense your feelings they can sense your
stress they learn all these different
things so when you put them in the bed
with you and then you want them to move
out
oh there seem to be doing really well
god they're a month old let's just move
them out let me tell you that kid
already knows when I go to sleep I sleep
in the big bed and they do not want to
move out they already know so then
they're all these temper tantrums and
screaming and crying and so forth and
then the parents give in of course you
know the natural soothing is another
thing you wrote about that was
fascinating what are they for French
that have the natural
right.you their charge needs the first
thing they need to learn to do parents
is to soothe themselves and to put
themselves to sleep so you do have some
kids that have colic so that's a
different story you know you have to
help them when they have some kind of a
physiological problem but your average
baby doesn't have that and so your
average maybe kind of likes its space it
likes its crib it likes to be able to be
in a space where it can do what it wants
and so you shouldn't project onto that
baby the fact that you know you really
want it in bed with you so that you can
make sure that it's okay you know that
it's breathing properly that in all
these things I'm telling you the
majority of babies majority like 95
percent of them do really well and so
the first thing they're learning is how
to self-soothe how to put themselves bad
and then this is just the beginning of
independence yes and what you want to do
is to have your child be as
self-sufficient and independent and feel
good about themselves so this is on a
trajectory where they feel good about
themselves yes yes this is this is
starting at you literally right when
they are born you can either put them on
the path of of helping them with their
independence or coddling them come on
that's right coddling it's the coddling
of the American child the American brain
there's a book out there how's the
coddling of the American brain it's a
very good book yes and it talks about
what we're doing to our kids by over
protecting them over coddling them and
one of the things that we're doing is
really unfortunately starting right away
the minute that you come home so if you
look online and you search how to get my
child to sleep you will see there are
parents out there whose child is 3 4 5
maybe 6 even who do
want to get out of the parental bed yes
they want they still want to sleep in
bed with mom and dad and so I think that
parents just need to be aware that
they're they're actually not doing their
kids a favor by doing that by
overprotective yes this the book how do
the the book calling of the American
mind
Jonathan hate and then there was another
co-author the book there versus kind of
the book of trick and the book of your
pet of your pedagogy of how to raise
successful people is they're they're
they're very important to distinguish
between like you're giving this example
you leave the hospital you good luck and
have fun what do you do how do you how
do you teach the end of Independence how
do you teach the self-soothing there's
so many other things like this and you
give great examples of this of just
really simple questions about if the
child would would you like to eat now
what choice would you like to eat would
you like to try and put your shoes on
yourself and just being patient with
their independence growing over time
that's right
you give them independence over time and
there's a lot of things that you can do
early on you know like even with a six
month old child and you know you can
give them different things for them to
sell they can eat themselves and give
them choices I think I just remember you
know when my kids were little that the
diet was really prescriptive you know
you were supposed to give them exactly
what the doctor said thank you
I don't haven't seen them recently they
were little jars of baby food I don't
know maybe they have phased out I don't
know but you know you but today they
have an opportunity to do finger foods
by themselves there's a lot of finger
foods and also it turns out that if
we're if we don't give our kids an
opportunity when they're young to try a
lot of different foods then when they
get older they're allergic so too now we
have this not
our genealogy yeah we have the nut
allergy a little pepper Demick of peanut
powder could potentially train them
their their build up the immune system
that's right so you know they can have
peanut butter on a little cracker and
that I remember that also that was
prohibited you can't know that the only
thing they were being able to have would
be bananas and applesauce and rice
I'm pretty boring diet right spell and
that's basically what they had and
hopefully that diet is out of phase out
of vogue now I should say because it's
really first is boring for the kids and
then they're not building up any of
these other adaptations to the food that
were eating so you know I just want to
mention one thing my daughter Janet
she's in Japan now and she's studying
the nutrition habits of the Japanese and
she wants to know like why the Japanese
live such a long time and why are they
they seem to be so healthy yes and their
children don't seem to be having temper
tantrums about the food you should go to
a nursery school in Japan and see what
they give the kids for this is a one
year old kid what did he do well he gets
Japanese food gets soup he gets all his
food in a little tray and he's expected
to eat that and no temper tantrum here's
your food there you go and you know you
can use a spoon too and so forth guess
what in porcelain dishes impor Celyn
whoa porcelain yeah yeah and then the
second the two-year-olds they get the
same thing three-year-olds get a little
bit more choice and but these kids
they're amazing well-behaved well but
I'm telling you you had that same story
of of when your children went to the
restaurant and was it Switzerland or was
a France and then there was a big issue
with the way they were behaving compared
to the children at the local it was
terrible it was yes we were in
Switzerland by the way all the Swiss and
the French children
they are all taught early on you know
that there's multiple courses and that
you have to sit politely and wait for
that course I think American children
they don't get that training so my
children of course moving over to
Switzerland at that point they were not
welcome in the restaurant because I mean
I just remember two of them were under
the table this is not appropriate in a
fancy restaurant this is great that
Jan's studying different cultures from
around the world and taking these best
principles and how to potentially make
it so that we can have more well behaved
maybe children starting one around the
world could start using porcelain dishes
as they as they eat and have a great
behavior and now but you know balancing
this out a little bit this is maybe this
is will be an interesting conversation I
have with you is it Amy Chou is her name
from - Chu Amy Chu from Tiger parenting
Tiger ball tiger mom Tiger mom and so
there's this let's just put these kind
of on let's pretend there's a spectrum
right there's one side is this tiger mom
Tiger parenting and the other side is
trick-trick pedagogy right the wash Way
wash way and then that there is certain
times then maybe like that if the
child's like refusing to eat I mean they
need nutrients right so then there's not
let me just tell you yes there's never
been a kid that starved himself to death
just want you to know okay but there's a
lot of very stressed out parents that's
true yes so this is an interesting
balance it's kind of like you know your
gift you're like you said in the in the
initial video you want to give children
enough of a of the deceive their
decisions and what they strive to learn
about at the same time as like if
they're refusing to maybe learn language
or they're refusing to learn some aspect
that's like really important to child
development maybe there has to be a
little bit of Tiger influence so like
for example there's a lot of kids that
don't learn to speak on schedule
yes yes and so what do you do about that
well some kids actually
need help and they need speech therapy
and in those cases that that's fine what
you're trying to do is help them
communicate I don't think the kids ever
complain about that so that's a valid
concern you know if your kid isn't
willing to eat their vegetables you know
and you have a temper tantrum you is the
parent well I don't think this helps and
it doesn't promote good behavior and
then it doesn't promote the independence
that you're hoping to get so one of the
things I mean food food choices somehow
in America seem to be totally Italian
all children are pasta lovers all they
want to do pasta pizza spaghetti more
pasta or spaghetti whatever you know
Pizza Pizza Pizza and so but I think
what's happened is that we're just they
were just following into all these
things that you know that were in charge
of the child's happiness we don't let
the child take responsibility in their
own way you give them some choices and
let them eat I tell you they won't
starve never seen a kid starve yet so
then there's like an authoritarian way
to say you have to eat your vegetables
and then there's maybe a more
collaborative way to ask questions about
why they're not eating their vegetables
and kind of work with them on maybe
making an incentive system for getting
them to eat their vegetables or so
there's a lot of different ways of doing
that what happens is that children
actually model what they see yes
so if you the parent are not eating your
vegetables why would you expect your
child to eat the vegetables or if your
child is eating this mush you know and
they see you eating I don't know fine
dining probably not going to be so
excited about eating their mush so yes
there's a lot of that going on
yeah there's there's so many stories
that you give around a building
independence and and trust with the with
children as they're growing up and this
is part of the trick pedagogy so this is
really cool that you would you would you
would go with you know and look at
coupons ever for when you went grocery
shopping together and you'd organize
them would they would or the kids would
organize them and then when you would
take them to to the store to Target or
to a store to to go and and and purchase
what you need for groceries that you
would sit in the in near the front or
even potentially drop them off once
they're old enough and and let them go
and shop through the store getting what
they need within budget within budget
and then and then slowly they would
build up their independence that way and
then they would even understand how to
use a card and where that money came
from how to balance the books at the end
of of the month to make sure that the
all everything was correct and these are
these little tiny incremental steps
towards independence and trust that's
right so I built those up as time went
on so it started with you know when they
were really little I would just remember
an had this rather large high chair
thing and she had lots of different food
on there and she fed herself whatever
and then she even cleaned out her her
version of cleaning up she swept
everything she didn't want onto the
floor
but then from there you know I always
took them to the store with me because
then I don't have any babysitters so we
all went to the store together so they
learned how to shop and as they got a
little older five or six we were coupon
cutters and they all on Sunday the paper
came and everybody had their little
scissors and they cut out the coupons
and as time went on they actually used
to organize the coupons and different
orders and like what do we want to buy
this week or what well don't we want to
buy and then they they used their math
skill they applied whatever math skills
they had you know to like
how much are we gonna save and and is
this then I had them that was back in an
era before they were actually before
people read labels my kids were reading
labels because I didn't let them have a
variety of preservatives and I wasn't
interested in them eating read number
five so they would they couldn't read
yet but they would look at the labels
like a very young age you can't buy this
because it's got this in it so that was
that was basically a lot of my training
it's so if you go to the store by
yourself you know with your friends you
know what to look for and what to buy
and what things to think about as well
not just I'm not in charge you can think
for yourself yes yes there's and there's
this that's another really good story in
here where the with was with swimming as
well is that rather than being so
fearful of the children entering into
the poulos go and within the first year
or two teach them how to swim and then
they become independent right and then
that was that hilarious story was it and
they jumped in the was Janet jumped into
the pool when she was 13 months old and
then some guy caught up her and had
jumped into the pool after oh no to save
her yeah you know she knew had a swim
already she was actually really miffed
and you know she's a 13 month old she
walked pretty early at 11 months and
then she could swim and so then after
this happened it was our local Swim and
Tennis Club I then had to alert all my
friends that she can swim and that you
know you do not have to rescue her so
you know she didn't have much hair you
know she's one of these kids that
developed hair later on so she was sort
of bald but she could swim and she could
talk so yeah it was pretty pretty
remarkable but I did that because we had
a pool in the backyard and I didn't want
to be in a position where you know I was
like frantic all the time the pool was
fenced but you know there's all those
stories
about kids get in when the fence is
somehow has a hole in it or whatever so
I didn't want to be one of those so she
could swim from one end of that pool to
the other
all three of them could do that and as a
matter fact the swimming became such an
important part of their life
that when they were like four years old
they joined the swim team yeah and then
when Ann was five and had the
distinction of being the best butterfly
so the champion butterfly swimmer for
the five and under category of course
you didn't have a lot of competition
this was Northern California so you know
most people don't teach their kids how
to do the butterfly you have so many of
these stories around like what we just
described at it was swimming or what we
described with with target and and
learning how to how to shop these these
stories of incremental independence now
like no teachers teaches about this I
think this is a very cool very cool way
to explain a reoccurring theme of what
parents deal with with children is that
parents think that you can do go and
join me do music do sports do
extracurricular do this do that and so
then where's the choice for the child
how does yeah how does the child get to
you know you balance this out with your
three girls that they were able to
choose what they found most interesting
at the same time as you would maybe ask
them questions about why they were
finding it most interesting or what they
would like to give up their time doing
instead these types of questions so
there's the there is the conflict
between me and Amy Chua the tiger mom so
she felt that she knew best and that the
child had to take a specific piano
lesson and constantly practicing a piano
so they got really good at it and over
and over and over again so there's a lot
of stories in her book she puts them in
the book herself of what she did to her
kids if they would not follow her
instructions and in one case one of her
daughters as three year old I think
that time she put her out in
below-freezing temperatures without a
jacket because the kid refused to
practice the piano so I think this is
you know not something that I would go
along with at all so one of my children
actually Anne was the one with the
incredible musical ability she could
play by ear at age five I gave her the
opportunity either you want to play the
piano or you don't want to play the
piano maybe you want to do something
else I guess if I were more like the
tiger mom I would like your to playing
the piano and I don't care what you're
thinking about and I mean there's more
stories from Amy Chua's book about other
things she did you know she would take
their stuffed animals and throw them
away you know they were and if you hear
about what her children think about
their childhood now how they reflect on
it they are both of them say that it was
very stressful childhood very difficult
for them but you know in Amy chew his
defense she thought this was the best
way to parent you know so she came from
of a society where you the parent knew
at all and they told the child what to
do and so you know she was doing what
she considered the best job she tried
really hard to be a really good parent
and this is the way that she this was
her strategy what I'm saying is that in
today's world that strategy only
produces kids that are depressed and
kids that feel like they have no passion
in life and kids that are really you
know we have an epidemic of kids right
now that are taking anti-anxiety
medications or I mean just look at the
statistics in college more than 60% of
the college students that have been
polled
feel that they have no control and feel
like they don't know they feel depressed
about the world and about their lives
rick yemm's being pushed down the
curriculum is being pushed down their
throats they can't decide what they want
to do the pair
pushing you know if they're not in the
right College or they're not taking the
right thing or these are there
statistics online that you know you can
look up and I mean this is not something
that um that is hard to find you know so
what I'm just trying to say is that it
is best if you give kids choice and let
them decide if they really want to do it
my theory with my daughter's was I want
you to try this if you try it and then
you don't like it well we'll try
something else
we'll give you that opportunity and so
Ann also was very gifted at tennis of
all things and and the tennis coach was
I don't think she ever recovered because
and did not want to play tennis it's
really sad she could have been like a
tennis champ Oh interesting
okay but she was happy she's a 23andme
chip and stabbed a tennis champ she went
instead of going for tennis
she went for ice skating and she became
you know she didn't she ended up going
through all those the series of ice
skating and ended up actually being on a
synchronized ice skating performance
team so you know she was out there
twirling around and doing all those
things that everybody gets impressed by
but so I let her pick and did the same
story happened with an 'wind opportunity
to work at the bio bio tech venture
capital company in New York yeah the yes
there was a there was a period where
where she had this great opportunity at
post college and then you as a mom were
like you know it's a great choice and
she wanted to babysit that's right that
she put up a little sign at this same
Swim Club where she had been the
butterfly champ
it's like babysitter available college
graduate and it was like bees and honey
they were like everybody wanted her and
she met so many people she had such a
great time she likes taking care of kids
she was babysitting and babysitting and
she had this family and that family
actually I think she still knows these
families and then she got this call well
actually she went to a job fair they
don't have them anymore now they're all
online but there was a job fair in Santa
Clara County and she went to a job fair
because her mom said this might be a
good idea what do you think after
graduating from college with this degree
in biology maybe you should think about
something else right yeah so she did me
a favor and went to the job fair and
then she came home and I said so how was
it she's like not really very good I
just met one person and then she was
like I'm gonna babysit it's like and
four years of college whatever and then
this one person turned out to be
somebody who phoned her I guess she gave
him a phone number and he had a position
available in New York and he's like
would you like to come and be
interviewed in New York she's like have
too many kids to take care of I don't
know about that I'll think about it
so she told me this it's like and what
anyway she didn't go and he called back
again a week later so it's like how
would you like to stay in the Helmsley
Hotel he I think he had figured her out
she's like well I'll think about it
and finally he she said to me well I
think I might want to go to New York
because I get to stay in this really
fancy hotel and they're gonna give me
really fancy dinners so I'll go for the
hotel and so then she went and she got
interviewed it was a great company it
was a Swedish investment company and she
liked them they liked her she they
offered her a job she came home and
she's like don't think I'm gonna take it
can you believe that as a parent how do
you handle that yeah
how long is this gonna go on anyway
tried to be supportive of their meaning
and purpose but that's right it was like
she really wanted to do this and so any
the long story or the short story at
this could be a very long story is that
you know she finally decided that this
was a good thing to do but she had to
decide it herself and she did and then
she moved to New York and it was a
fantastic company and a great job
investor international and she loved
them yeah and and that was the beginning
of her Wall Street career you know Janet
and Susan also have similar stories yeah
yeah
these are reoccurring stories of parents
and their relationship with their
children where the the most meaning and
purpose for the child comes from their
ability to pursue what they want their
entire life and that is very tough
sometimes for a parent to say that
there's no money in that and then that's
when the whole thing comes to a crazy
whirlwind of well I've had some students
whose parents I mean really the parents
needed a psychological support because
the child decided not to be a doctor or
a lawyer or you know go into business
but instead they wanted to go into the
arts and I understand parents you know
because you know a lot of artists don't
earn any money just like my father was
an artist and we kind of starved so I
understand that but you know there's
there's ways to get them to talk to them
about it give them an opportunity to try
what they want to do who knows you know
they could easily be super great actors
just like my former student James Franco
he's a great actor yeah and you know
yeah I know he wasn't his parents
weren't so sure that that was the right
career for him neither
that's in the book - yes only the arts
and the philosophies end up actually
being even more well-paid
in the future and the age of automation
yeah I know there's still a lot to
really wanted to touch on birth order
but that's you know this is a
complicated thing like it's a big like
parental dynamics and family dynamics
changed a lot when you have just one
child versus when you have two or even
three then the older might take care of
the younger if there's just one is there
a lot of you know secure attachment or
insecure attachment those are very
important traits for also this long-term
like what happens to that seed between
the ages of 0 & 5 you had 3 so you had a
you know how many years apart well they
were all born within five years within
five years yeah okay so they were all
kind of they were close yes there was a
lot of jealousy there their typical
their normal their regular kids and so I
put Susan in charge of taking care of
Janet when she was 18 months old and she
liked it and Janet Janet actually liked
it too but you know I was there
supervising so I can tell you that I
devoted the mid all my time to being
with the kids because I had been a
teacher for a year or two and then back
in the 1970s it was not in vogue for
mothers to work so the pressure on me
was to quit as a matter of fact I was
teaching when I was pregnant and the
school rules were that the minute you
showed the minute you could see you were
pregnant you had to leave because you
were giving bad ideas to the students oh
really
so being able to be responsibly teach
that process yeah yeah so fortunately I
was able to last all nine months because
I was so tall I am so tall still right
and then somehow
you couldn't see that I was pregnant and
you know cuz they somehow Susan managed
to stretch out as opposed to go forward
but otherwise I would have had to quit
so anyway I did stop teaching at that
point and devote a lot of time I had
nothing else to do you know like they
didn't let you do anything else you were
just I was mrs. Stanley with jet ski I
didn't even have a first name yeah your
husband Stan physics professing at
Stanford and traveling a lot you're
raising your three children a lot of the
time now you have these really powerful
stories as well of you teaching the
girls about how to save how to save
money for you know wrong and wanting to
renovate your floor saving money from
the grocery budget every single month to
be able to renovate the floors and like
these stories go a really long way for
teaching kids about independence and
respect trust collaboration kindness all
this kind of stuff I want to I want to I
want to explain how you know this ended
up kind of like starting for you with
with the scholastic journalism
thirty-six years of this night which is
crazy it's ten years older than I am
and I'm just like how have you been
doing that for that long that's how you
become a master at something right is
when you've done it that long you you
know you really playful with kids they
love you because you play with them
you're not an adult you're with them as
yeah and then that that helps a lot but
then there were serious cases of you
know maybe you know drinking happening
in the high school you're like that's
not okay and other kinds to see you know
one to be serious right I don't want to
be playful and balancing those those out
throughout the year so tell us about
this you know this thirty six years
building up this glossy journalism up to
seven hundred kids now at paltu Media
Arts Center right yeah so I started that
in 1984 and there were only about 19
kids in the program at that time and I
wanted to be a journalist I'm trained as
a journalist but I couldn't you know
there was no inner
so you were either driving to San
Francisco to be a journalist or you
weren't gonna be a journalist so I was
like okay guess I won't do that I'll
just teach journalism instead and so
luckily I got that job teaching
journalism I had to I just had two
classes actually the beginning class and
then another more advanced class they
were really small then I taught English
and others and I also taught math
because they needed another teacher for
that and what I discovered after just
one year of teaching by the system that
they told me to do to use was that no
one was learning nobody okay so it was a
lecture based I had a book called press
time I don't know if it's still in print
but basically you read the chapter there
were questions at the end you answered
those questions you took a test on
Friday and then you move to the next
chapter so this was the whole book and
at the I mean I was realized that oh my
god I'm so bored
well anyway how are they doing you're
doing five times a day
that's right repeatedly oh no so I'm
they had a choice the choice was to
throw away the curriculum get a
therapist help me write or just to quit
and so I decided I would just take a
risk and I threw away the book get away
the curriculum yeah and instead you know
how they have like newspapers free for
all the you know you go down pick up a
newspaper so instead I just used the
regular local newspaper free I you know
it was like you're rebelling there's you
know you're being Copernicus you're all
the teachers are like don't do it don't
do it you're gonna get in trouble that's
right and so I did that but anyway I
waited to be fired they didn't even
notice they never noticed they threw
away the book they just noticed that the
kids seemed to be pretty happy and but
the other thing that I did that they did
notice that my classes were
collaborating did you know that
collaboration
until just even maybe eight years ago
what was it called cheating cheating no
collaboration was not allowed and here I
was in 1984 85 86 and my kids were
collaborating it's like you know you've
got a whole cheating a group of kids in
here cheating all the time and you are
sanctioning it so they gave me a couple
weeks three weeks to fix it it's like it
cannot continue they cannot keep talking
to each other the next time I come into
your class I want them to be listening
to you no talking no collaboration none
of this and so I was gonna be fired yep
so what did I do hmm so I decided that
who was I gonna get to help me the kids
the kids so I said to them I told them
what was happening I told them the next
time that I was gonna be observed I
don't want a single sound in the
classroom just read your book don't do
anything whatever so they came in and
the next time it was silent and when I
talked the kids just looked like well
they look sort of brain-dead but they
looked they didn't say a word and so I
passed and they they asked me how did
you make them do that I did not tell
them how I did it it's not it's not part
of the deal and then you you had this
really also profound moment of not only
learning about tossing the curriculum
and enabling collaboration and a
mentorship between the students but also
you had this moment where you saw the
seven max Macintosh's and then you apply
for a grant and you got the Macintoshes
into the classroom and then the students
as well as some of their parents were
coming and helping you guys get used to
the information technology age for
journalism that's right so I could
hardly wait to use these my program when
I first started all those years ago I
was using a typewriter yes and the kids
were cutting their stories out with
exacto knives yes I was handing out
exacto knives to all the kids there were
only 19 but they all got him and pasting
the stories up with hot wax
doesn't it sounds like horse-and-buggy
right she was ready to school on her
horse no that's close and so then when
the Mac came out I was so excited about
this I got this grant in the state only
problems I didn't know how to use them
so I had to I there was the only one
group that could help me because nobody
in the school know how to use them and
that was the kids so I told them I said
I got this incredible grant I've got all
these things the new technology do you
want to see let's open the box together
and so that's what happened
I still remember all those students that
helped me with this whole technology
thing it was remarkable and so that's
the collaborative program me
collaborating with the students they
know a lot more they were able to figure
this out faster than I was yeah yeah and
so when I needed something I had a great
group it was a bunch of parents that
worked they were connected with Aldus
corporation so all this was sort of
predecessor for Adobe who helped and did
a lot of things to help me and then also
I would frequently take groups of kids
to Fry's we all went to Fry's deep-fries
was like was a great place to go you had
this giant big horse out in front wasn't
a real horse of course you know as a
cowboy statue and there were always a
lot of people in there it was like it
had this vibrance and yeah we had a
great time they put this all together
you have this really interesting policy
of mastery that I that I find so
interesting rather than all the stress
levels that come with testing of for the
kid and the parent both which is a crazy
relationship at home is this stress
level of testing testing testing that
you give this ability for mastery where
the student isn't necessarily did they
don't have as much stress because you
say that you know as many times you as
you need revise revise get better at
answering these questions figure out how
to to best
become educated yourself and then you
can get that final revised grade at the
end and then that teaches mastery
decreases stress levels then you have
mentorship in the classroom you have
like editors of the journals so they
like vote their own editors in and then
the editors will will work with the
articles being written and they design
we have some cool images of the students
actually designing in the Adobe it's
crazy how the Mac went from what was it
85 is when you had yes once look at 87
87 to this and that's like crazy how
much isn't that incredible yeah so you
know I should just say we have about 10
different publications now and it's not
just me I'm not the only teacher so I
have six other teachers and one of the
first people that helped me set this up
was a guy named Paul Kandel and he's
still there and he supervises three of
the programs and then I have two other
teachers that fortunately they decided
Michigan weather was too cold and so
they came and they're here so we have
you know magazine called Verde which is
a news magazine and then C magazine
which is a copy of the New York Times T
magazine so we just copied their idea we
handed it out with the newspaper so but
the original publication is the
Campanile e Campanile e is a newspaper
it's three sections about twenty four
pages long sometimes longer and every
section and every story is designed by
the students so us they are in charge of
everything and if you saw what it looked
like people frequently see these
publications and like you know are the
kids really doing that are you doing
that and I was like you know the kids
are doing that not only are they doing
it they're doing it better than I could
ever do it and they're using funds from
local businesses for advertising in the
paper that's right it's self supported
that's huge because then they're
learning entrepreneurship and
relationship building and their
communities like industry level work
right there
all like that so you know we have other
publications as well we have like a
broadcast program every day in focus and
then we have website program voice that
these kids are on the story like
immediately and we have a photography
magazine proof I mean we we even have us
we have a sports magazine all the kids
that they they look like professional
football players and everything else and
pictures and they're beautiful wonderful
and they're just kids and it's a sports
magazine called Viking and then also
recently Paul Kendall started this
program called entrepreneurial
journalism entrepreneur kids get to come
up with their own ideas all
self-supporting again so they have a
science magazine and a Travel Magazine
I'm telling you we're a magazine factory
yeah ten publications there's about ten
publications oh wow and includes the we
have a radio program KP ly in addition
so the idea is to say to the kids you
know this is century of media if you
would like to be part of one of these
media programs welcome we want to hear
what you have to say what are your ideas
for a story and which medium do you want
to be part of we have a lot of different
mediums and so just pick the one you
want to be part of and that but the
teaching style and all those programs
are the same teaching style so everybody
uses the same trick method they use the
same mastery bathe method so it's the
program isn't just tied to me you know
because people say oh it's just you that
was able to do this other teachers can
do this as well as a matter of fact all
teachers can do this it's the culture of
the classroom that promotes a sense of
competency in the student
yes and so when you give kids an
opportunity to revise and to make
mistakes and then not to be penalized
they learn that it's okay to do it
yourself and then the pressure for
grades drops and the plagiarisms
eradicated plagiarism I don't ever have
a plagiarism problem there is no
plagiarism no stress in the household
then so I did the same thing in my
English classes so they would write
essay you know Romeo and Juliet or you
know catch To Kill a Mockingbird all
these essays they wrote them until they
were a level but I wanted the kid to
write the essay not the parent correct
so as long as there was no grade
pressure then the parents didn't care
they're like sure you write the essay to
get it right but when there's grade
pressure and you the student gets just
one chance to get an A then of course
you know there's tutors and there's
parents involved and and so that's why a
lot of teachers they make the students
write in class what do you do in the
real world in the real world in industry
you have a project that you're
constantly tinkering with and deploying
and and devote further developing and
making better over time so this is the
real world is not of filling in bubbles
on a and getting it right the first time
so the real world so it's projects it's
working on something it can be in social
studies you know a paper in social
studies it can be in science you know
you work on a project all the subjects
the kids should have an opportunity to
learn from their failure and right now
school teaches kids that failure is one
of the worst things you can do because
if you don't do it right the first time
you don't get the right grade and then
they average those grades and then
there's a lot of grade pressure
so unfortunately we've seen the end
result of all the stress which was this
big scandal with the cheating getting
into colleges and depression and
depression
and anonymity and cyberbullying on the
internet and things like that that are
also kind of tearing apart at a
community and love and kindness kindness
there is no kindness in most of these
situations unfortunately because it's a
winner it's a win I have seen kids wear
their grade is 90 knows that eighty nine
point five and it's not eighty nine
point six you can't get an A and you've
been working the whole semester I can
tell you a lot of your viewers will be
able to identify with that yeah eighty
yeah the classic your 0.1 percent away
from away from us yeah three to a four
on a transcript that's a from B to an A
that's a that's a major deal and there's
a lot of fight for can I do something
for extra credit
anything anything extra credit yeah it
was so crazy so just let them work on
the project that they're working on life
is a series of projects yeah yeah it is
not a series of multiple choice tests
yes yes it is a series of long projects
that's right in there and you have to
find meaning and purpose in every single
one of those projects that's how we know
we're raising successful people so one
of the things that makes people happy in
the world is having something that they
really care about a passion project and
the majority of employees today don't
have that feeling about the job they're
working in and so if the companies could
give their employees some control of
what they're doing I'll let them have
some say in the workplace Google gives
twenty percent time Google gives 20
percent projects related to the mission
outside of their work and then same
thing with Salesforce also gives time
for them to write yeah so my way my
latest idea global moonshots org I
started this nonprofit and the main
message is give kids 20% of the time to
work on project
of their choosing it can be crocheting
it can be gardening it can be writing
apps it can be developing a robot but
they should have an opportunity to do
things that they care about or they can
be even magazines or newspapers or
whatever I'm doing so that program my
journalism program is a 20% time program
that takes up about half the school but
there's that all kids need to have this
kind of an opportunity and then they
develop ideas about what they want to do
in the world yes correct
and then hopefully they'll do things to
help save our planet
yeah we have a lot of faith in
Millennials and Gen Z to to work on the
hardest most pressing issues but you
have you create environments you create
cultures parents and communities and
teachers create cultures that enable
them to do so when you give them the
autonomy with the with the newspapers
with the publications that you have to
to write about complex issues hard
things are written about sometimes that
you know sometimes you do have to step
in and say and say something about you
know about it and and I think that's a
very important process for people to for
us to make culture that gives the twenty
percent time to to creative endeavoring
you also teach about the importance of
grit and growth mindsets like when
someone doesn't get the editorial role
there's sometimes there's what like 20
people running for five editorial
positions there's released and then you
have these great stories where the ones
that don't get that' toriel role are
just upset and that then luckily you're
able to work with them to where they
continue building up their work writing
articles and partaking in and then what
they do is then they apply to Harvard
they apply to the school saying that
with the story of I didn't I didn't
become the editor but I continued
working really hard and persevering
through that with that grit and that's
continued tenacity that's right and the
schools like that better than getting
the senior position because it shows
that you know you're part of the team
and that you know how to work through
setbacks I mean this is not a tragedy
but a lot of kids well a lot of their
parents think of it as a tragedy and
it's not it's just one of the it's a
bump in the road that you need to learn
how to navigate and so that's that's
what they learn and that's what I try to
teach all my students though they're all
part of this is a team I mean all these
companies they're all team efforts it's
a team and we need to work together as
part of the team and the family is a
team - yeah you know and if you aren't
working together as a team in the family
you know what happens he falls apart
yeah yeah the and we were chatting about
the importance of bloom to Sigma of
mentorship that the kids that get
one-on-one mentorship perform two
standard deviations past the mean and
you can see here there might be a good
example for you to illustrate this for
us but you have different ages in the
the Media Arts Center sometimes you have
the seniors or juniors that are in the
positions that are higher helping
freshmen or sophomores with an actual
process they're not just authoritarian
like saying perform this action in in
Adobe but you're actually having them do
a mentorship student role where the
student is practicing the skill that
they learn to do themselves that way he
actually becomes them they learn it they
can then go and teach others how to do
it this mentorship system is critical
the mentorship system is critical so the
first child in a family gets the most
attention and then the second the second
most and third is false you know so each
child gets the less mentorship and less
from the parents but if you set up the
culture in your family that you all work
together and you help each other and you
teach each other that makes a huge
difference and that's what I do in the
classroom so I have 12th graders 11th
graders 10th graders and the 10th
graders know the least right so it's no
problem you know do you don't know
anything that's fine I don't care
we will help you learn it
and if you make a mistake no problem
we'll do it again
and so you actually every kid in the
class has a buddy
they all have buddies what our cubbies
is their cubbies yes yes and so what
used to happen is I would put them
together and and all the older kids
would start fighting over which one they
wanted for their cubby I want this one
no I want that one no I'm gonna get this
I was like we can share the cubbies yep
plenty of cubbies yeah but but there's
these relationships then last the whole
time you come into the class you will
you can feel it in the class there's a
sense of camaraderie a sense of caring
and you know the editors are in charge
I'm I stand by the side and my coat
advisor
his name's rod Satterthwaite he stands
by the side we both stand by the side
and the kids take over they need advice
they ask us as opposed to we take over
and we ask them it's a very different
thing yes and I also have two coaches so
to speak one from The Wall Street
Journal one from the Washington Post and
there are people that retired from those
positions and they are amazing and they
come in and help with they support the
program and there's a lot of retired
journalists out there that would be in a
position of being also you know they're
they're basically aides in the classroom
they do not have a teaching credential
so legally they can't have a class by
themselves but I'm telling you they're
invaluable and that's a way for for
people to give back who might have been
in a career and then you know have
retired and then one another thing that
they they can do yes and they can they
can actually do this in an English class
as well and does or social studies class
it doesn't have to be just a journalist
I'm sorry yes there's mentorship for
every industry to student level for any
field ok and that's so critical for
building we all need mentors you know
everybody needs support and
even even you know the principal needs
support you know everybody needs support
yeah yes that's one of the things and by
the way Google has a system of
mentorship and support yes yep not what
this is NEETs like you said creativity
is being transferred into industry and
more time for creativity industry just
like more time for mentorship industry
now I want you to teach us about the
trick in marriage this is very
interesting because like marriage is
first of all this is like a divine union
with another person so you a very divine
thing this is we don't just have a child
with anyone this needs to be a very well
thought-out process both psychologies in
place both finances in places so it
kinds of variables and then once that
happens I think we were talking the
divorce rate is very high in the unit
like one in two almost is is going under
divorce families I came from a divorced
family Ron as well we are we're seeing
kind of some maybe people aren't able to
work things out maybe their trick the
trick pedagogy is not being applied to
marriage as often but at the same time
sometimes it is important to realize
that it's not the right fit so this is
balance it's difficult teach us about
about it applies trick-trick is
important in all aspects of life it's
especially important in marriage because
marriage marriage is one your happiness
depends number-one on the person that
you decide to marry because that impacts
your life
and so a lot of people don't think this
through
but before they tie the knot they should
think this through and then once you are
married and have children it's really
important to remember that that person
is the number-one person that you should
respect and what happens when you get
married is that somehow the fact that
they're married you're married and oh
you know now they're legally bound to
each other there's like oh well maybe I
don't have to respect them so much
anymore because you know that they can't
do anything and they can't go anywhere
anyway it's kind of like oh they're
there so when as respect starts to erode
the whole thing starts to fall apart and
what you're doing is you're setting a
model for your children yeah um
disrespect and then when you expect your
child to respect you they don't do it
they do what they see not what you say
and then it moves from disrespect to
lack of trust and then lack of
collaboration and then the worst of all
is no kindness so and it just keeps
piling on top of each other so it's
important for both parties to remember
why they went into the marriage in the
first place and to respect that person
and even when that person starts to
change you know we all aged there's what
are we gonna do about that you know who
no one solved that problem yet so you
know different things happen along the
way and you're supposed to take good
care of the other person especially if
you have children together and that's
what I would like to just remind people
that when they get a when they separate
get a divorce the everybody hurts the
children hurt especially the partners
that were together
there's no erasing the past it's still
there
all the families the relatives and all
the people that came together for your
wedding they're all suffering with you
so maybe you should just think about
this you know in another way and think
about perhaps not doing this
because it just creates long-term
problems for everybody you know you talk
to adults and they're still sad about
the fact that you know 30 years ago
their parents got a divorce and it
doesn't end so I'd like to encourage all
parents to use trick in their marriages
and trick with their children and see
what we can't do to make to change that
statistic of you know 1 & 2 getting a
divorce anyway yeah that's my that's my
so I've been married for minute a half a
century 50 years okay did I just tell
you it's not easy it's not easy so my
husband is a high-energy particle
physicist and let me tell you how much I
know about particle physics zero right
of course I learned a lot about it and
the process of being married but we have
very different interests but and it's
important to support your partner in
their interest he was busy running off
to spare me lab in Chicago doing
experiments all the time and I mean I
would go over there I didn't understand
anything but then he supported me in my
teaching you know you have to be your
partners in life yes and the best thing
you can do is to be partners in life and
then teach that to your children yeah
so there's why it's teaching it's it's
it's so critical but that with a stimuli
that ends up occurring for the child
when they're born into the world of
parents are arguing or parents aren't
doing trick that can they can lead it
and although all that can lead to
potential trauma and harm down the line
I just wanted to say one more thing you
know there's a woman named Esther Perel
yes I really like her first name because
it's like nine and she has a whole
program on marriage and I think her
program is outstanding and she talks a
lot about
what happens you know when somebody
strays you know if your partner does
something that yeah and you know I
recommend that people take a look at
that and follow her programs and
understand because I mean one incident
like this can break up a marriage and
that marriage can last you know could be
80 years of and or 650 years of a
marriage and you know I think that's
they should take her course yeah if
they're it's very hard being you know 20
20 or 25 or whatever age it is and
looking at parents that are potentially
getting divorced and whatnot and saying
you know hey is one instance of cheating
really worth you to to not be able to
try and work something out
really you're gonna spend you know the
next 40 years away from each other why
did you even get together in the first
place think about that there's like all
of this to still yeah still unpack on
that front I wanna I want to hear your
thoughts about the transition from the
shareholders to stake holding this is a
very interesting kind of like
interdependent capitalism transition
that is happening especially with the
automation age and with children being
more involved in in creative and the non
repetitive tasks that are not in the
crosshairs of software but rather that
our that our that the instead of instead
of the profit going just to the
shareholders of the company now we're
thinking about how do we give profit to
the employees to all of the customers
that I've actually built the company
with their purchasing power how do we
give the profits in the community that
the company is in that kind of an
equation teaches about what you've seen
with that with this transition that's
occurring out well so this transition is
happening now where companies are
thinking about sharing the profits with
with the people that are actually
participating and like for example
Amazon would be a great group to start
doing this we're all buying things on
Amazon and
I mean the most is the richest man in
the world and we're contributing to it
so it would be well great if some of
those some of that wealth which he could
never spend in a lifetime
he couldn't spend it in ten lifetimes
could go to help the people that are
needing it we have so many people today
that need to have more income and it's
worldwide but you know here just in San
Francisco alone I see the need for for
income but you could actually have a job
you could when you buy things you could
get some kind of a credit for it there
could be some ways that it could feed
back to you I am working with a man who
has a company called heavenly organics
and he goes into areas of stress like
where there's war and he hires people in
those areas and what he says that is
really important is that people don't
need money they need a job
they need respect from a job and so if
we can somehow figure out in these big
companies jobs ways that they can share
their profit so that you become a you
know somehow you know you're sharing in
their their wonderful success yes it
would be it would be great now
Salesforce is another great company that
is trying to do a lot of these things
and you know I want to say that Marc
Benioff is one of my heroes for
supporting proposition C you're working
with about the homeless here in San
Francisco and I don't know if you had
any other ideas i anything is
interesting for teachers as well because
they can you know you have a stake in
the child's life outcome the better you
do as a teacher if we can create a
better
feedback system for that you could that
there's a steak holding that you have in
how well they do so you're more
dedicated just like just like physicians
as well physicians and patients is
another great example that if there's if
there's no steak holding that's when the
physician can just you know prescribe
whatever that you that makes money
instead of prescribing things that would
increase the longevity and the health of
the patient that then they can have a
stake in so it's kind of a transition to
just the steak holding so so I
definitely do have a steak and all my
students which is part of the reasons
that I'm doing what I'm doing and I
don't just care about them as doing well
in my class I care about them as human
beings and but I've always done this
I've always considered it just a big
family just a larger family one that I'm
actually honored to be part of their
lives and I think the doctor that is a
stakeholder does the same thing you know
they're not just trying to make money
and prescribing something for you
because they're gonna get money from the
pharmaceutical company they actually
care about you as a human being and so
we need to write these things a little
more clearly into more transparently
into the code of teachers and students
and doctors and patients that is some
malevolence that's occurring well I
think that in medicine it was pretty bad
for a while you know that you were
primarily concerned with making money
the number of patients you saw per hour
and you know the I think that that was a
real that still is a problem I mean I
think one of the reasons that Ann went
into 23andme is her goal is to put
healthcare in the hands of the consumer
you want to know what your DNA is what
is saying about you what can you prevent
from happening elderly and so like for
example one thing that I found on my DNA
was that I would had a predisposition to
diabetes you would never guess because
I'm thin but it turns out
that that I have this predisposition and
so it helped me a lot because then I'm
really careful when I I don't eat a lot
of cake and cookies and sweets and
things like that but if I didn't have
that test you know I would just be
eating up like crazy and then I found
out by accident that a large percentage
of diabetics are thin I don't want to
wait and have that happen to me to find
that out right the preventive strategy -
yeah it's a health right okay this I
mean we could talk for hours I love you
so much I love your impact so much it's
just thank you so much I love being here
you guys are great you're doing amazing
simulation honestly this is a fantastic
thank you thank you you're inviting me
we we're very very grateful that you're
doing what you're doing we have a couple
quick questions that we like asking on
the show no way out okay fine okay good
okay
all right the first question is are we
alone in the cosmos it's a very good
question sometimes I don't think so
sometimes I think there are other beings
out there and I am not sure why but you
know I get these subtle messages that
things happen for a reason
and because I never started out trying
to do these things I never started out
with the mission of I want my daughters
to be heads of major companies I was
remember I was like could you stop
babysitting please and it's like maybe
just have a job like everyone else so
yes I do think there might be others out
there yeah yeah mmm this could be
another entire discussion yeah more of
these abstract thinking questions
because yes we do like discussing what
could potentially be happening outside
of outside of earth maybe pre-birth and
post-death what happens in those time
periods and what is uh what are these
little these little signs that we see
you there there are lots of little signs
that we see and I know they're out there
I just haven't had time to investigate
fully but maybe on our next show maybe
you can help investigate and then help
me let's do it let's have the young the
young ones to the business ask them all
so we're feeling about this yeah yeah I
think kids have a I think that they
think there is something out there so
they're closer to coming from wherever
it is than we are okay and second
question the show simulation so we must
ask you are we in a simulation
well I think that I'm real this is me
I'm real I'm not being simulated but I
guess there are opportunities to
simulate me but this this is the real
thing I love your show and I love the
simulation thank you for asking this is
a very good thought experiment to run on
so many other ways as well simulate what
it's like to have life evolved on a
planet and what would happen if certain
variables were tweaked a little bit
about how a civilization evolves it
would be it's so interesting to think
about that because we are in a process
now of tweaking our planet we're not
doing it it you know it's not
intentional it's because of the climate
issue intricacy and so it's changing a
lot and it will continue to change and
so there's an interesting it's a very
interesting question yeah yeah running
these is very good I hope we get more
young people running some these thought
experiments as simulations and seeing
what it can do to
to enhance their creativity an
imagination the last question we like to
ask okay what is the most beautiful
thing in the world
the most beautiful thing in the world
I think it's birth and spring and life
every spring and every birth
it represents beauty for all of us and
hope beauty and hope and that's what
makes the world a better place when we
have hope and we don't lose it that's it
so that's you thank you thank you thank
you this has been such an honor well
thank you we're so so deeply
appreciative becoming out of the program
Oh watching us honestly it's great being
here thank you so much for inviting me
my god though the work is so crucial for
our world and we we hope please everyone
we check out how to raise successful
people the link is in the bio to all of
us there's work go and check out the
work the book is $10 cheaper as
pre-order only $18 right now becomes $28
on May 7 seventh so get the book early
pre-order the book everyone also give us
your thoughts in the comments below we
would love to hear from you teach us
about what you were thinking about this
episode go and talk to more people your
family your friends your communities get
them starting with this trick pedagogy
get it disseminating to more people
let's start practicing this around the
world as there's already teaching this
around the world and spreading it let's
keep doing it together support the
artists and entrepreneurs that you
believe in you have us here at
simulation if you believe in us our
links are below support us help us grow
support the other ones in your
communities the young people sub support
them being artisan entrepreneurs as well
huge shout out to Ron Vargas our
producer and director we love you very
much thank you thank you build the
future
manifest your dreams into the world
everyone we love you so much thank you
for tuning in and we will see you soon
[Music]
you